[Music]
[Music] She
can fight. Are you
still here? evacuate quickly.
Aren't you scared? You guys are
scared, right? No, you're
not scared. She's the
bubble of a hero. An
ordinary person like me.  That's
why I
can't leave him alone.
If I don't teach him at least a little bit about the mindset of ordinary people, that hero will die soon.
[Music]
Nanao wanted to see what happened to you as well. [Music
]
[Music]
No more.  I don't have the stamina to decide. I
decided to jump in at the moment I created an opening. I took aim at him. [Music
] This is
truly the underworld. [Music] Okay, let's
go.
[Music] I've been
waiting for this.
This is the only time to concentrate on attacking.  The wind that protects the whole body is
biased towards the back of the good guy, or it's
bad. He
recovers quickly.
Decide what part of his body will be affected.